merci nous sommes de retour sur le
plateau de la voie est libre avec kara
bouziane pour le ps paul garrigues pour
la ligue des droits de l'homme jean
baptiste lemoyne pour les républicains
il fallait qu paillard pour le syndicat
alliance police nationale
alors on parlait de l'état d'urgence
faut-il ou non le constitutionnaliser
c'est la grande question quel serait
l'intérêt finalement jean baptiste one
donc c'est la constitution de la vème
république
elle prévoit déjà un article 16
elle prévoit un état de guerre est donc
finalement elles prévoient des
situations qui sont déjà très extrême
là il s'agit plutôt de langage de m et
d'encadrer un état d'urgence donc c'est
pas c'est pas absurde sur les temps ça
ne suffit pas soi même
il faut que nous puissions également
jeudi adapter notre arsenal législatif
d'ailleurs au sénat nous avons déposé
avec philippe balle pendant la
commission des lois un certain nombre de
collègues une proposition de loi pour
renforcer justement la lutte contre le
terrorisme
j'ai un certain nombre de propositions
également que je mets sur la table et
donc il faut également derrière qu'on
vote ça assez vite parce que c'est pas
seulement adapter la constitution qui
permettra d'être efficace à face à une
situation qui encore une fois je le dis
va durer dans le temps et où il faut
qu'on soit tous en situation de
vigilance
parce qu'en réalité la façon dont vivent
les israéliens peut-être qu'un jour nous
on sera avec le même état de vigilance
voilà il faut avoir ça en tête carbo
viennent vous êtes vraiment opposé voit
cette inscription de l'état d'urgence
dans la constitution est ce que ça ne
permet pas au contraire c'est la lande
de l'encadrer et d'avoir des règles un
peu claires et précises mais l'état
d'urgence qu'il est il et il est partagé
à tout le monde n'est pas pour tout on
n'est pas contre il est en discussion
mais quelles seront les conditions pour
lesquelles vous pourriez voté pour cette
mesure
eh bien il faudrait déjà que que le
parlement il est un droit de regard sur
cet état d'urgence
aujourd'hui c'est le cas on a on a des
bilans mais il faudra peut-être le dire
et l'écrire aussi celle qui semble
c'est ce qui semble se profiler après
l'état d'urgence qu'est ce que cela
représente
alors moi je suis quand même inquiète
quand on fait le parallèle entre la
france et israël qui vient d'être fait
sa mue en homme ça me gêne à une
solution s'impose un état de droit un
état de droit n'est pas recherché nous
frapper partout
tout n'est justement et donc il faut que
nous soyons tous visent ils ont barré ni
ceux des réseaux les recevoir et
l'associé société là et bien à
intérioriser ses réflexes à nous d'en
moi j'aurais préféré qu'on travaille sur
comment faire pour éviter le danger en
fait si on avait déjà sur son était pas
pris jeudi avons effectivement à ces
régimes autoritaires mais laïque
après tout un pardon mais les
occidentaux déstabiliser le monde arabe
de ce point de vue là tout le monde
d'ailleurs porte une responsabilité
n'exagère pas
on est là je veux dire je pense qu'on a
mis le doigt dans un engrenage fatal de
dislocation et en est en partie
responsable des occidentaux alors 310 me
perquisition administratif 550 50
procédure judiciaire douze lieux de
culte ferme et 33 cents soit 3 cent dix
mille perquisition cinq procédures pour
terrorisme ça c'est dans l'état
d'urgence un état d'exception où l'on
donne aux autorités civiles des pouvoirs
de police exceptionnel et on ne peut pas
être à l'abri de dérive dérive tout à
fait tout ça c'est justement il faut pas
en cas d'arrêt ça mais le problème c'est
quand même c'est avaliserait et
banaliser un état de restrictions des
libertés individuelles et avec notamment
un gars qui sont du parlement on a aussi
quelque chose d'essentiel dedans c'est
l'idée qu'on transfère un pouvoir du
juge qui a une certaine indépendance ou
préfet qui n'en a aucune
statutairement à c'est pas un procès
faux préfets et ça c'est quand même
grave quand il ya des parce que qu'ils
faillent assure la sécurité oui mais ce
qui sont essentiels c'est aussi comment
défendre les libertés sont salis
terroriste aurait gagné son assurer la
sécurité pendant renonçant aux libertés
fondamentales
et dire que celui qui tente dans la
constitution et intégrant essentiel des
libertés individuelles le juge
indépendant se voit dessaisi au profit
du pré crise c'est quand même pas
quelque chose à faire à la légère et
aussi sur des faits parce qu'on nous dit
oui monsieur par les libertés messieurs
que c'est pas la mienne je vois comme de
t'en avec ta d'urgence ipr
l'interdiction de réunions nature à
provoquer entretenir le désordre la
dissolution aussi d'associations dessus
avec de tels textes et quelque chose
d'aussi larges et indéfinie l'ordre
public
on aurait très bien pu dissoudre les
syndicats agricoles en bretagne
non mais la france ne mène l'entretien
des voitures et maisons
franchement j'en sais pas qui seront
pouvoir demain mais de donner des idées
tout législatives
annecy qui existe c'est pour ça qu'elle
est dans aussi dans la rue pour dire il
faut faire attention la dite société
civile et même si aujourd'hui c'est dit
c'est à faire entendre c'est important
de le faire entendre il faut quand même
téléspectateurs ont vu leur vie changer
je suis pas persuadé franchement donc
mais france je crois que les libertés
c'est quand même quelque chose de trop
précieux pour qu'on se dise il faut
qu'on que j'attende que la mienne soit
mis en cause pour m'y intéresser je
crois il faut quand même on a un
équilibre des institutions qui vaut ce
qui vaut qui est perfectible mais avec
certains garde-fous comme l'indépendance
judiciaire
et c'est quand même pas rien d'y toucher
d'autant plus que je m'excuse de
l'assister personne n'a pu prouver que
c'est un juge qui aujourd'hui est
empêchée de démanteler une filière
terroriste
beaucoup disent même que si les juges
antiterroristes avait plus de moyens la
justice cus de moyens on aurait
peut-être qui prévient sont deux choses
et aussi dans toute cette logique on se
pose pas du tout la question du pourquoi
un certain nombre de jeunes tournent
dans cette folie et qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour prévenir et ça me fait un peu
peur que ce soit même absent du débat et
d'un temps des grands responsables
politiques dire comprendre c'est comment
s'est excusé ça ma folle parce qu'on ne
combat bien que son contrat
l'embêtant c'est quand on comprend ya
plus de solution simple il ya plus de
solutions miracles avec paillarès que
plus de sécurité plus de moyens donnés à
la police
et en même temps la garantie des
libertés individuelles ça va de pair ou
est-ce que c'est très compliqué ce qu'il
faut se dire que ben voilà on est en
guerre il faut des mesures
exceptionnelles et c'est comme ça vous
voyez les choses
je pense que depuis depuis janvier
depuis janvier 2015
certaines choses ont vraiment bouger et
on n'a plus la même
notions de sécurité et la sécurité n'est
plus appréhendée pareil quand quand
j'entends monsieur garric dire faut pas
laisser le pouvoir aux préfets
seulement le préfet est le représentant
de l'état le préfet dans le département
est chargé du secteur de la sécurité des
personnes et des biens
c'est lui la première personne qui est
en butte aux problèmes de terrorisme et
celui qui doit prendre la décision
rapidement
donc à partir de ce moment là qu'il y
ait une corrélation avec ce que peut
faire un juge
est-ce qu'il peut être demandé par un
juge dans le respect des lois
fondamentales ne pose aucun souci mais
le préfet doit avoir vu sous voire de
décision et il doit l'utiliser avec le
respect des lois des institutions et de
la république le préfet n'est pas exempt
donc dans l'état d'urgence s'inverser
quand même l'administratif à elle
pouvoir
un rapport sur la biologie disent je
suis d'accord avec vous mais sur
l'administratif quand quand vous avez je
vous en ai parlé tout à l'heure quand
vous avez un signalement potentiel de
radicalisation ou quelqu'un qui va
commettre un acte terroriste
à 23 heures la réaction qu'on peut avoir
est techniquement comment comment on
peut régler ce problème là puisque
actuellement la loi ne le permet pas
donc il est vrai que quelque part il
faut quand même donner aux moyens les
moyens aux enquêteurs et par là même à
la justice puisque après si on a quelque
chose qui sort de ces perquisitions
administrative le pouvoir judiciaire
reprend la sphère en main et les gens
sont jugés
je pense qu'il faut qu'on fasse une
séparation entre la partie qui peut être
la partie technique et amener la faire
et son traitement
je rappellerai quand même que la police
c'est avec la gendarmerie
ce sont des auxiliaires de justice qui
travaille quand même sumann justice et
qui font des actes qui sont quand même
la plupart du temps jugé légaux et dans
des conditions qui sont vraiment très
particulière on a bien fait d'ailleurs
qu'il ya quand même un certain nombre de
me faire quelques assignation qui ont
été contestées le juge jed
on a cassé très peu en réalité je crois
que le préfet aussi avec discernement
en ont utilisé les outils qui était à
leur disposition et honnêtement
faut il y avait fait du ménage à faire
je dirais moi je vois dans l'yonne on a
fait un point mais je dire il ya eu des
armes de guerre saisis et des munitions
il ya eu enfin et sur des individus bons
qu'ils regardent pas bambi toute la
journée à la télé je veux dire faut voir
on a quand même quelques quelques
profils un peu inquiétant 1 et donc on a
traité on a traité près 4 il ya 400
personnes je crois qu'ils ont sont
assignés en france du 3000 perquisition
mais on a plusieurs milliers de
personnes fichier s et ses sorties
encore besoin
ben d'être en état de vigilance encore
une fois d'un point de vue un peu
exceptionnel je suis d'accord avec
monsieur gary et c'est à dire que après
il faut que notre loi soit adaptée et ça
permettra de dents finir avec l'état
d'urgence voilà les députés ont quand
même a adopté en commission des lois
donc jeudi des amendements notamment que
rien juge administratif qui serait
compétent un quant aux procédures de la
police administrative est ce que ça
c'est rassurant et c'est super ce genre
de choses qu'il faut tendre mais écoutez
j'ai je vous avouerai que j'ai pas tout
suivi
mais comment passer effectivement devant
l'assemblée nationale
en tout cas ce qu'il faudrait c'est
qu'on ait des garanties que le droit est
toujours respectée et quand vous avez
des perquisitions
si la personne conteste la perquisition
parce que malheureusement et
heureusement d'ailleurs que toutes les
perquisitions ne débouche pas sur sur
des terroristes sinon ça serait vraiment
inquiétant et c'est à la personne de
prouver de d'amener la preuve ggd
chiffre à ils sont donnés par par le par
le syndicat des avocats 3 189
assignations à résidence
soixante et une contestation qu'est-ce
que j'ai d'autres étouffées
mais mais mais mais c'est parce que vous
avez il n'y a pas longtemps que j'ai lu
le cas d'une personne parce que elle
était en différend avec une salle
voisine elle se retrouve avec une
perquisition sur une dénonciation un peu
calomnieuse on n'est pas à l'abri de ça
donc il faut qu'on fasse attention et on
nous a signalé comme un centre de calais
je pense qu'effectivement passer par le
juge judiciaire peut-être permis de
trier seul qui était nécessaire et
évidemment personne ne dira qu'il en
faut jamais parce qu'un mais aussi un
certain nombre sur des dénonciations ou
sur des apparences et sur des choses que
je sais pas si vous pouvez le dire ça
n'avait d'ailleurs est ce que vous avez
vécu ce genre de choses
en bourgogne franche comté par exemple
ces derniers temps les situations qui
sont décrites là où on est et ont été ou
étaient étudiés sont connues de toute
façon puisque il ya eu des référés au
tribunal administratif à dijon où la
personne a été débouté et il ya des dire
des choses qui ont été faites il est
vrai que à partir du moment où on peut
prendre une
on peut prendre une image un peu
paysanne de dire que malheureusement à
un moment ou un autre ont fait pas
d'omelette sans casser d'oeufs en deux
mots je suis désolé parce que c'est le
sujet pourrait très vague mais on est à
la limite de la démocratie en ce moment
vous êtes vision par rapport à ça en
tête brady effectivement la france est
une démocratie
le procès absolue ça n'existe pas on est
plus ou moins démocratique on l'est et
encore aujourd'hui plus que la moyenne
des pays du monde mais ceux des
certainement pas une raison pour ne pas
être vigilants contre tout ce qui
pourrait le faire reculer
et pour pas essayer de plus démocratique
la france est demeuré démocratie les
citoyens doivent s'armer d'une vigilance
active pour voilà empêcher de tels actes
donc je crois que nous sommes en train
de dériver non car moi je crois que la
france est une belle démocratie qu'on
doit protéger tous tous les citoyens
mais c'est surtout qu'on doit se poser
les vraies questions les bonnes
questions pour apporter les bonnes
solutions pérennes parce qu'un état d'
un état d'urgence ne va pas durer a du
talent et hernan et sinon en masculin
est dans un état policier
très bien merci beaucoup en tout cas
tout
c'est d'avoir participé à cette émission
où vous retrouverez jean-baptiste
lemoyne et karam dizaine en congrès donc
à versailles ce sera sans doute avant la
fin du mois d'avril
je vous rappelle que vous pouvez voir ou
revoir cette émission sur notre site
internet bourgogne point france.fr la
semaine prochaine nous vous proposerons
une émission commune à la bourgogne et à
la franche-comté à l'occasion de la
percée du vin jaune
nous serons à lons le saunier pour
évoquer de nos touristes mais l'avenir
de nos vignobles
pour l'heure c'est le 12/13 qui se
poursuit avec l'édition nationale et
internationale très bel après-midi à
tous